As you are moving around between apps,
you probably notice that
from a user perspective,
Android doesn't announce changes
in app state. It doesn't announce,
that it's low in memory or ask users
to close apps to free up resources.
In fact, it does everything it can to make
the resource limitation to the device,
invisible to the user.
That means keeping
the foreground app running smoothly,
and switching between apps seamless,
and that means killing apps
in the background.
And it does that
if it needs their resources
to make sure that the foreground apps
can continue to run.
So we know that as soon as your app
is visible, its lifetime is as perilous
as that of a Stark at the Red Wedding:
likely to die without notice,
but ready to return from the dead.
That tells us some very important things
about how our app should behave
to be good citizens
and provide a great user experience.
>From a system perspective,
onPause and onStop are signals
that our app may be killed eminently.
So we need to clean up any resources
that need an orderly tear down
such as closing any
open connections or sockets.